is there a connection between air
pollution and the coronavirus lockdowns
have helped the environment as factories
closed flights were canceled and ships
load clear waters in the canals of
Venice clear skies over Delhi and see
that every day but studies show poor
quality air prior to the crisis could
have made people more vulnerable to
covert 19 hi I'm Ben for zulan let's
look first up at what the scientific
evidence says about pollution and corona
fatalities
it's a map that many of us have become
painfully familiar with the red dots
showing coronavirus cases around the
world the number of fatalities has been
especially high in northern Italy in
Spain around the capital Madrid similar
scenarios this has prompted some
researchers to examine the environment
in these regions more closely
among them is Yaron organ a geographer
at the University of Halle all the
research until this point was focusing
on what background diseases these people
that died from coronavirus has are there
smoking do they have any cardiovascular
diseases that have diabetes but I
shifted and other researchers also from
around the world started to shift it
from the background diseases to the
environmental factor in his study Yaron
organ examined the level of air
pollution measured by satellites before
the outbreak
he focused on nitrogen dioxide the gas
emitted by cars planes and industrial
activity another factor that he was
interested in concerned the geography of
the regions where the number of deaths
were high that of the fatalities in
China in Tehran in in the north part of
Italy and in Madrid these are places
surrounded by mountains mountain ranges
and valleys so mountains actually close
the area which means if there are
pollutants any kind of pollutants in
this area especially in winter when you
have a very cold weather the air moves
downwards very cold very stable
conditions the pollutants stay close to
the ground close to the surface and the
mountains do not let it spread do not
let it disperse in other places and so
the population are exposed to high
concentration of the pollutants and
there have been other studies such as
this one from Shandong University in
China which found that long-term
exposure to air pollution attacks the
immune system and damages the lungs or
more precisely the cilia of the lungs
which make up the first line of defense
against inhaled germs that can make it
much easier for pathogens like the
corona virus to advance into the airways
if the environment is clean we will be
clean and we will be healthy but if our
environment is polluted we will suffer
more and that was exactly the main cause
to look at the environment and we should
keep it clean there are of course
multiple factors that influence how
severely the corona virus strikes but
the environment may play a bigger role
than we thought
DWS Android neuron John has taken a look
at the studies for us as it has air
pollution made us more vulnerable to
catching the corona virus or actually
dying from it so it's not about catching
the virus but more about the chances of
you dying from the virus we know that
air pollution increases the risk of
these underlying health conditions like
lung cancer and asthma that leave your
body more vulnerable in the face of
infection and scientists are worried
that the more people who are exposed to
long term bad air the more people there
are in a region who will then suffer
from these health conditions that lead
to these complications what about the
the science behind this can the virus
basically ride on particulate matter and
make its way into our lungs so we can
quite strongly say that this isn't the
case every epidemiologist and air
pollution expert I spoke to said that
there's basically no reason to suspect
that this is happening essentially the
the World Health Organization has made
very clear that the virus is transmitted
from person to person and this happened
through droplets in the air and
sometimes on the surfaces that these
land on and this is of course why it's
so important that we all wash our hands
and avoid touching our faces and that we
physically distance from one another
droplets and surfaces words I don't like
anymore what are the takeaways here ajik
I think the main takeaway to know is
that if you suffer from one of these
underlying health conditions if you live
in one of these polluted areas and you
do have these chronic conditions like
asthma or lung disease then yes you are
probably a higher risk of complications
from the virus what's less clear though
is what does it mean if you live in one
of these areas but don't suffer from
these conditions could the air pollution
still have an effect on your survival
chances if you do contract the virus
that's something that scientists don't
know yet but what's important to
consider is that hospitals which are
dealing with large number of patients
who do suffer from these diseases are
more likely to be overwhelmed so even if
you don't have the virus if even if you
don't have an underlying how
condition if you live in an area with
high pollution your hospitals might be
more at risk so what should governments
be doing to ensure this doesn't happen
again that we're protected from this I
mean post-crisis I guess everything's
going to go back to normal at least
that's my fear and it's not going to be
good for us or the environment I think
that's a fear of many environmental
groups as well and campaigners have
medical professionals people working in
the field of air pollution are really
calling for a drastic change where we
don't just go back to business as usual
and obviously it's understandable the
government's right now are kind of
focused on limiting the spread of the
disease and trying to avoid this huge
disruption to the economy that the
lockdowns have created but people are
also noticing the reduction in air
quality that we're seeing right now and
asking how we can make this last longer
so some suggestions that maybe are the
most obvious and basic ones are to
accelerate the shift to from fossil
fuels to renewable energy sources that
are less polluting so solar panels and
wind farm that don't spew these gases
that are actually damaging our lungs the
other big consideration is how to change
transport and how to move from these
kind of diesel and petrol based vehicles
to electric vehicles or even to public
transport these are the kind of
considerations that groups are trying to
get governments to consider right from
the very start and not leave till after
the pandemic Paget's thanks for having
you on the show now to your questions on
the corona virus is our science editor
Derek Williams the pandemic has brought
cleaner water and cleaner air should we
do lock downs regularly to improve
environmental quality I'm not a climate
scientist but I read a riveting article
by a well known expert in that field
just this morning and that touched on
this question which is why I decided to
try to answer it here she makes it very
clear that although we'd all love to
believe that there's some kind of
environmental silver line
to this disaster that is the kovat 19
epidemic there isn't one because co2
lasts for so long in the atmosphere and
because we've been pumping it into the
atmosphere for so long what's happening
now might improve air quality
temporarily but it won't really do
anything to slow the biggest factor in
in Environmental Quality which is
climate change she also makes a very
compelling case that going into regular
lockdowns willingly accepting the
suffering and death that they also would
cause that it wouldn't solve our
environmental woes the only thing
that'll do that she says is changing a
system that's based on extracting co2
from the ground and pumping it into the
atmosphere when a kovat 19 patient is
ventilated does the virus just die off
over time mechanical ventilation via
intubation is a very invasive last
resort procedure that's only implemented
when a patient's oxygen levels fall
below key thresholds when when organ
damage is imminent because not enough
oxygen is reaching the bloodstream what
the Machine is supposed to do is keep
someone who's critically ill alive long
enough to allow their immune system to
clear the pathogen and fluid from their
lungs to help them reach the point where
normal breathing will provide enough
oxygen again we still don't have any
medications to treat the disease so at
that point the body's immune system
either wipes the virus out and then
subsides to levels where the immune
reaction itself isn't lethal or the
patient dies the ventilator is a
last-ditch attempt to give the immune
system the time it needs to take care of
the infection on its own interestingly
attitudes towards mechanical ventilation
for kovat 19 patients are shifting among
experts at the moment but but that's
another topic maybe I'll talk about that
next
what do post-mortem observations of the
lungs and kovat 19 patients reveal about
5% of the patients who contract coded 19
will grow critically ill and the
symptoms that put them in intensive care
pretty much always involve the lungs
quite a few histological studies have
looked at exactly what kind of damage
the virus does there and what those
studies basically reveal is that a
critical infection usually disrupts
oxygen transfer in the lungs by causing
a massive immune reaction that leads to
inflammation and creates this sludge of
fluid and dead cells that block oxygen
transfer even more when things reach a
critical point patients enter what's
called acute respiratory distress
syndrome then they have to be ventilated
and many died subsequent autopsies show
that the tiny sacs and their lungs that
allow gas exchange are packed with a
gummy yellow fluid made up of mucous
white blood cells from the immune system
and dead cells from the lining of the
lungs